joining me today is a writer and
columnist at Colette magazine as well as
a philosophy major at Columbia
University
call me news welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me on dude I had to
change my shirt because your shirt
looked so pressed and starched and
professional sigh Ronnie cuz I normally
dress like a complete slob we're the
same black hoodie every single day yeah
but I thought Reuben report you have to
bring a game let's do it I should have
worn a tie but here we are
alright there's a lot of reasons that I
want to talk to you you were sort of I
think put on put on my map and put on
sort of the the IDW map and the map of
all of the people that that care about
the issues that we talk about here about
what was about five or six months ago
something like that something like that
your piece I want to get the exact title
right was the high price of stale
grievances and that was in kulit and you
know I just had Clara on the show last
week so we're gonna talk about a lot of
things you've been writing that I want
to talk a little bit about what it's
like to be a student at at a university
these days especially one that leans
pretty far left and all sorts of stuff
first just tell me a little bit about
yourself where you're from how you grew
up well that kind of stuff from
Montclair New Jersey just 30 minutes
outside New York City nice suburb you
know I had a pretty typical middle upper
middle class upbringing and great
parents and out of out of high school I
I was going to a music school actually I
was dead set on being a jazz musician
and I still played Josh trombone nice
but along the line I ended up shifting
paths and going into philosophy and
enrolling at Columbia where I have two
more years how do you go from jazz to
philosophy there's probably some
through-line there right I don't know
that there is honestly I think I think I
just loved both of them and realized at
a certain point that just going to
school for music was limiting so yeah
yeah so you said middle class or upper
middle class yeah you have did your
family have any particular political
beliefs where you guys
political at home any of that my my
mother was nearly a Marxist um she I
remember her talking to me about marks
and Durkheim when I was three and four
years old well she came from the South
Bronx immigrant Porto Rican family very
very poor in the 70s when the South
Bronx was the picture of crime and just
decay and she she was very smart woman
ended up getting a trying to get an
anthropology degree but she passed away
of cancer well while she was getting it
but no sheshe I was I was exposed to two
marks and Durkheim and some other other
Marxist thinkers when I was I could have
told you their names when I was five
years old Wow
my dad is bit of a libertarian but I got
less of his his he was working much at
the time so yeah so that's a real mixed
yeah household of politics no did you
sort of lean one way or the other
yeah I always leaned heavily left if I
if I leaned anywhere at all yeah I mean
as early you know my the beginning of my
political identity was definitely
anchored around identity politics and
especially black identity politics yeah
I was you know 24 it was at 2013-2014
when black lives matter started cropping
up I was at that point very much
enthusiastic about that movement I was
posting on Facebook having seen a police
shooting to the effect that this is this
is proof that the system is rigged
against black people so that that's more
or less what I was politically as of
maybe five years ago so yeah that was
very much in my upbringing it was in the
water in my and my social environment
and intellectual environment growing up
how much of that is part of the whole
thing of just being around a certain set
of young people that believe a certain
thing so that you all sort of believe it
together whether it's ultimately true or
not yeah I think I think we're social
animals and and we're heavily
incentivized psychologically to not
break ranks with the norms of our social
group so if if those norms are that you
have to believe in the god vishnu shiva
then most people are gonna grow up
believing those things and it takes a
kind of a rare personality to be a
contrarian in that context and if the
norms are you have to believe in
systemic racism you have to believe that
america is a unique evil then people
will grow up believing those things and
and likewise if the norm is you know a
abortion is murder and there is only one
God and it's the Christian God and
homosexuality is a sin then most people
in that context will will end up
believing those things so yeah I mean my
as far as my upbringing I think I can
remember meeting precisely one
Republican and he was my fifth grade
history teacher and he was such a good
history teacher that you know in this
public school that it kind of made up
for the fact that he was a Republican
because all the parents who want their
kids to get ahead wanted them in his
class right huh so you know there's
something there there yeah yes yes but I
guess yeah long story short it was very
much of an echoed very much an echo
chamber very ideologically siloed yeah
okay so so far your story I think sounds
pretty consistent with a lot of what's
going on with with young people how well
how old do you know 22 22 okay so you
said in 2013 so only about five years
ago you're 17 you're sort of in this
thing this is the beginning of black
lives matter
when did you start realizing that
perhaps it wasn't as much of a positive
as it had sort of been laid out to be
well I think it's it's hard to
reconstruct one's own narrative after
the fact but I remember one thing being
significant which was when Michael Brown
was killed in Ferguson I remember being
in my first year of college taking
taking a class at Julliard and we were
talking about this killing and it was
just obvious from the point of view of
most in the class including the
professor that this was just another
in a long line of examples of black men
being brutalized in the country that
fundamentally does not want them to
cease to succeed and I don't know what
like what it was it may have been
because you know either out of roommate
who was from from Arizona from a very
different kind of political climate who
was skeptical of this and I didn't even
know how one could be skeptical of this
it was so jarring to meet a person I
liked that or many people I liked that
were skeptical of the things I took for
granted yeah were you guys able to get
into it because that's always one of the
big problems that people can't do this
stuff with their friends anyway yeah
well the thing is I think we were such
good friends at that point for a
political reasons that you know no
amount of politics was gonna was gonna
destroy that but I think I just spent
one night reading the complete testimony
from from from Michael Browns friend and
from the police officer and I came away
thinking well if the police officer is
telling the truth then that was a
justified shooting if his friend is
telling the truth then it was
unjustified but I don't know who was
telling the truth and no one in my class
knew either but everyone had the same
opinion so that I mean I remember that
being significant I remember remember
speaking up about that like when was the
moment that you were kind of going right
I gotta say something about this I'm not
sure I'm not sure that I spoke up about
it I'm not sure I would have had the
confidence yeah to speak up about it
yeah
were there are a couple other things
after that because I find it to be one
of these things that once you see this
thing for what it is that then it sort
of happens very quickly I think a lot of
people that watch this show and
acknowledge that because I think it's a
lot of former former lefties or whatever
you want to call it that kind of see one
moment like you just laid out and then
they start looking at other things and
going wait a minute maybe that's not how
it is maybe that person's not racist
just because I disagree with them on
this or whatever the yeah I guess I
could I can point to two other quick
moments one was once I once I arrived at
Columbia I heard of this guy John
McWhorter who I had no reason to believe
anything about at the time
but I just went I don't know on a whim I
went to the library and just searched
his name and pick the first book I could
find and it was called authentically
black and it's a series of essays he
wrote in the early 2000s about the fact
that it's viewed as authentically black
to can constantly point the finger at
white people for any given problem in
the black community whether or not the
evidence bears that out and because it's
viewed as authentically black there's
this incredible taboo on anyone who
thinks differently
and I was reading these essays and I
remember thinking oh my god this is this
is right and I've never heard a black
person say this out loud but it's it's
obviously right and I didn't know you
could say that I remember that that
moment being significant but still the I
mean these subjects are so hard to talk
about I do remember doing at some point
doing MDMA and this is where the most
people have their break yes I guess this
maybe makes the the red pill analogy a
little too literal there you go
but I do remember I mean because you
know I I don't I don't enjoy being the
black person at odds with most black
people around me are getting accused as
I sometimes do of being self-hating or
an Uncle Tom
like I don't enjoy that that's that's
very much a cost of what I'm doing
psychologically but I remember remember
doing MDMA and I was talking to a black
friend of mine about race issues and you
know if you've ever done MDMA you know
it just puts you in this totally clear
headspace where you love everyone around
you so much and you love yourself and I
remember we were talking about race
issues and I was articulating more of
the kind of points of view that I
articulate
now and I felt so silly that I had ever
had a hang-up talking about these things
in any other context and you know after
that I just I felt like like there's
no reason I can't try to approximate
that more and more often
of course it's it's much harder when
you're sober
but yeah the analogy though or the
metaphor of the red pill really has some
value here how did that conversation end
up I mean an MDMA laced conversation at
all I feel like ace all MDMA laced
conversations go well yeah I mean
something has to be yeah it is I just
yeah I think I think if we had more and
more enter conversations with a mindset
of the person I'm talking to has reasons
to believe what they believe and they're
coming from a good place then a lot of
conversations can go well that said I've
had a lot of conversations with people
since then that have gone extremely well
I sorry extremely poorly yeah and have
ended quite bitterly yeah and I want to
get to some of that and some of the
things that people call you and all that
so you have these you know a couple of
successive moments of waking up when did
you finally start talking about this
stuff you know I think I had talked
about it here and there with with
friends and family but and I had been
trying to write about it a bit for the
school newspaper and just writing on my
own but not publishing over the past
year but I think what what what did it
was when Kanye tweeted I like the way I
love the way Candice Owen thinks mhm
when he tweeted that something about
that moment was so inspiring to me to
see someone who nobody on earth would
question their quote blackness because
in many ways Kanye is viewed as as the
picture of blackness
however one cashes out that term - just
to see him bring cranks to see him break
break the taboo even though he did it in
a way that even though he's not an
intellectual he said crazy things about
slavery that that aren't true and
endorse someone who I don't I don't see
myself as having very much in common
with namely namely Candace just the fact
that he was willing to
the taboo at all someone of his platform
was so inspiring to me that that that's
when I started writing for Colette yeah
so what was was this the first piece you
put out for Claude I think that was the
very first it was a very first piece
okay so the the title of the piece as I
said was high price of steel well yeah
this one was different this one was on
this one was about Kanye and Candice
this was oh right right so thank then
this one got more traction the one
you're sorry okay so I think this is so
I don't think I was you were on my radar
from that one although that probably
that whole thing the whole Kanye thing
just sort of broke in such a crazy way
yeah there were so many pieces written
okay but so let's back up then so then
when you write this piece about Kanye
and Candice now you know Candice is a
friend of mine yeah she's been on the
show I like her she has some tactics
that are that are not my thing but that
that's her thing and I can disagree with
people and all that your basic feeling
though this was a net good no matter
what are there risks though in you know
taking somebody like a Kanye and having
that be the moment that wakes up people
because you don't know where he's ever
gonna go with things or was just the
action itself enough I guess time will
tell I think it is inconvenient that
Kanye I love his music and I've been a
fan for a long time but he clearly has
some narcissistic elements to his
personality he's clearly not someone who
deeply researches the subjects that that
he sometimes talks about so he kind of
took a very blunt sledgehammer to a
taboo which I appreciated but there are
there are serious downsides to that
namely when he says that slavery was
slavery was a choice something that
ignorant seems to discredit his taking
the sledgehammer to the taboo when I do
think they're separable in principle I
also think when he said you're talking
about when he said that on TMZ right yes
and his counter-argument to that was
that he means that it's it was sort of a
mindset yeah I think was his counter
right yeah right yeah so just that that
soundbite reads so awfully because it
seems so uninformed regardless of what
his his intent was there that it can it
can seem
discredit that he did a good thing on
the net on net balance yeah and yeah I I
also I you know I have reservations
about Kent Candace Ellis as well I've
seen her reason in ways that I think
don't make much sense although I have
some points of agreement with her too
but like I said I think I think there's
a taboo that is incredibly strong right
there there are lots of black people who
agree with some version of my takes on
race and are absolutely mortified to say
so because there's this massive taboo
yeah and that's also why for again
whatever my disagreements are with
Candace it's like I see her as someone
that's trying so desperately to break
something the very thing that you're
talking about so it's like if she's
using tactics that maybe I wouldn't use
or you know tweets in a more hostile way
of people or whatever that I wouldn't do
it's like I don't know that I I'm the
one that should be telling you how to
behave
in that regard yeah does that make sense
to you
not so much only because I feel like
there are a lot of people who might like
what Candace says on race for example so
when Candace says you know to go goes to
a college and says and sees all of all
of these black students reminding her of
the history of Jim Crow which they
didn't even experience and using that as
as a rhetorical weapon and Candace says
listen you were born in 1990 right I
completely agree with that that is that
is a message that needs to be hammered
home which is that histories in the past
and we have to be getting past history
but you know when she says that you're
on the Democratic plantation mm-hmm I
think that is a kind of exaggeration
that is not useful because people with a
different set of intellectual priors
will just hear that and be immediately
closed off to whatever else she says and
you know I've also heard her just reason
in ways on Joe Rogan for example when he
pressed her on climate change kind of
appealing to a sort of feeling over
facts kind of way of thinking which is
actually quite characters
of the far-left but she I think she also
gets treated unfairly and she gets
assumed to be a sellout which i think is
is ridiculous ridiculous assumption to
make about people in general unless they
make it absolutely clear that they are
so I've you know she's she's someone I
would be happy to talk to at some point
but I'm happy to set that up if you'd
like to make it happen okay so you write
this piece now this is the first public
piece that you've written about this
stuff did you have any idea what kind of
reaction you were in store for no no II
threw that moment yeah I think it got
retweeted by christina hoff sommers and
jordan peterson and sam harris and and
some other people and it really really
blew up and yeah that was
psychologically distressing because you
know I'm a normal person so when I go
from having 50 Twitter followers to
10,000 and in a week or something like
that that is a pretty life deranging
moment and it was it was just kind of
physical stress a low-level physical
stress all day and not sleeping as much
but you you get I think you get you'd be
surprised what you can get used to so we
were you shocked where you were getting
defense from and where you were getting
outrage from or I assume you expected it
at least at some level yeah no I don't
think I was shocked by that I mean I
knew at this point I knew at this point
exactly who would be very pissed off by
by my my opinions and at this point I
had to resign myself to being it to
those people being pissed off at me and
no I'm not I mean I'm not surprised that
the quote IDW types liked my work
because I like a lot of their work so no
I guess that wasn't that wasn't so
surprising yeah so when you then wrote
the piece the high price of state the
high price of stale grievances which was
also Inquilab you started with a quote
from felonious monk that I thought it
was was sort of worth diving into here
they tried to get me to hate white
people but someone would always come
along and spoil it
there's something about that quote that
strikes me as so relevant to what's
going on right now that we are not
looking at people as individuals and
that every time you do you will be
pleasantly surprised because most people
are not walking around in this state of
hate yeah yeah no I think it's striking
I mean and I I I'm juxtaposed that quote
with another from the New York Times
from a New York Times op-ed published
last year which argued that black
children should be taught to fear white
children based on the history of racism
in this country and the quote was as
against our gauzy national hopes I will
teach my boys my black boys to have
profound doubts that friendship with
white people as possible right so that
got published in the New York Times in
2017 you know Sarah John got hired
having having written incredibly nasty
tweets about white people in 2018 by the
New York Times right it's it's it's
disturbing to me that you can't you
can't really find at this point on the
left even on the mainstream left just
the simple articulation that a person's
race does not matter to their moral
worthiness to their intellectual
worthiness it is it is an irrelevant
character you can't find the language of
of
appeals to colorblind humanity virtually
anywhere on the left at this point that
that is disturbing to me how shocking is
it to you because I think people are
still kind of shocked you know I've been
banging this drum for quite some time
and I think I see people waking up to it
now and I'm like man how didn't you see
this you know these these last couple
years because it's so obvious to me that
we've gotten here ya know it is SH I
mean III do remember growing up you know
in the public school system in my town
we would have Martin Luther King Day
assemblies is very diverse town maybe
twenty-five thirty percent black and
sixty percent white and we would we
would get the
you know that I have a dream style ethic
around what it means to be a human and
how important rather unimportant one
skin color is and it seemed like such a
seems like you're such a good argument
to me and it is the best argument with
regard to people's you know the assumed
I guess what I mean to say here is that
I've been in spaces at Columbia for
example or conversations where my being
black it was obvious to me that there
was an assumption of of moral worthiness
or of a kind of heightened moral
knowledge that I would have as a black
person that a white person wouldn't have
and you know I think I think I'm not the
first to make this analogy of course but
the religious analogy and the analogy to
original sin is pretty apt because it I
mean the way though this has a lot to do
with black history also because the way
I oh the way I see it they're kind of
two ways to study history there's the
conventional way which is you know you
study World War one you study the causes
and consequences read different takes on
on on the significance and once you've
studied all you need to know you move on
to the next topic but then there's a
religious way of studying history which
is I mean it's not enough to know the
facts we have to go somewhere on Sunday
and you know every single week and learn
talk about the same stories over and
over again so this is you know it's it's
the difference between how an atheist
learns about the life of Jesus and how a
Christian learns about the life of Jesus
and relearn's at every week for the rest
of their life in my view how we're
looking at the history of race relations
in this country the history of racism we
are more and more putting it in the
religious category of history where you
know I can read a piece about the
history of lynching in the new york
times almost you know once every two or
three months right well I mean lynching
is a decade's old crime at this point
and Abhiyan sheezus right obviously it
was a Hey
stain on this country's legacy you know
but then the number of deaths that that
is is the highest amount quoted in New
York Times with regard to how many black
people were lynched in this country is
around four thousand right every single
year twice that many black people die of
homicide and I you just don't even hear
about that in the New York Times so what
do you make of the fact then so this is
something that like a Sean Hannity will
talk about he'll say that exact and now
if you say and then people say that
somehow that makes him racist because
he's focusing on black on black crime or
something like that so how do we have
that conversation then because I think
partly what's happening is the outrage
you know someone mentions it he happens
to be someone obviously on the right I
don't know what his intentions are I
don't know the guy but he yeah he's at
least talking about it what I just said
people aren't talking about yes but then
pays a heavy price to talk about it that
then has the chill effect that it's like
people are like alright I'm not going to
talk about it so we can look at the
crime statistics in Chicago every week
and you you should care about these
statistics where the people are white or
black or whatever but people are just
like I don't want to touch it because
yeah I don't want these labels yeah it
is it is decidedly I mean this is one of
the reasons why you know I'm I don't see
myself as a natural ally to Candice
Owens for example because there's so
many other things that she says that you
know that I don't agree with and I guess
it's the Sean Hannity problem too
because if you can't criticize a Sean
Hannity or a Candice Owens for all of
the things that that they're saying that
are unjustified by the evidence
mmm-hmm you know it's Candice Candace's
case it might be climate change or or
whatever it is for Sean Hannity could
could be other things then I guess you
just have to be able to make these
subtle distinctions but at the end of
the day homicide is the leading cause of
death for young black men aged 15 to 34
according to the CDC it is not the
leading cause of homicide for any other
race
or age group can we talk about that that
I mean is it the case that we're we're
so close to white people turning the
hoses on us again to the Sean Hannity's
and and they're supposedly deplorable
you know followers that that were just
so the threat of white supremacy is so
ever-present of resurgent white
supremacy that we can't talk about the
leading cause of death among young black
men that that that is not sustainable I
mean the the fundamental problem I see
with how the left in general thinks
about race is that the concerns about
race and racism are totally unattached
to the degree to which black people are
suffering on any given issue right so
we're talking about the leading cause of
death for young black men and I I never
read about this in the New York Times
mm-hmm and I and I know that I won't
write so this is this is a problem that
is central it is it is bigger than the
problem of police violence it is bigger
than you know then the problem of
microaggressions it is bigger than the
problems of systemic bias and yet there
is there's virtually no concern for this
on the left because the the way I see
many progressives think about race
issues is a perpetrator side concern
which is if the perpetrators of the
problem are white that it's worth
talking about if the perpetrators of the
problem happened to be black and it's
not we're talking about the problem with
that is that it's untethered to any
concern for the level of suffering on
this side on the victim side do you
think it's a fair estimation to say this
is the new racism in a weird way like
it's it's almost uncomfortable to say it
but I had an educator in the UK here in
the summer Catherine verbal saying and
that's basically what she said that
these people are now the racists that
the racist ideas of the day are actually
coming out of the left now I don't want
to use the same tactics right I don't
want to sit here and be like they're all
racism
blah blah blah cos we know that that
doesn't really get us anyway the general
idea of that do you think that that's a
fair way to frame things I I wouldn't
frame it I mean the way I would frame it
is that there is a kind of racism on the
left and it's the kind of racism where
the New York Times hires a writer who
says that who celebrates the idea that
white people stop breeding right and
doesn't apologize for it yeah
no concern with how that how that's
going to translate to you know white
people in this country who have vastly
less privileged than you know the tech
writer at the New York Times and what
about that statement that they issued
defending her yeah you saw that where it
said something about the hate she gets
as a young asian woman it's like what
that that's now yeah that you can that
you get to be racist because you've
gotten trolled online right well you
know I mean that so coming back to the
question that is that that is I'm happy
to call that a kind of racism for sure
it's the only reason I would say there I
wouldn't go as far as to say they are
the new racist is because they are still
racist on the other side and I fully
expect there to always be some amount of
races in society and some amount of
racist incidents like the way this is
another problem with the way many on the
Left think about race is that they tend
to view the problem of racism kind of
like we view the problem with smallpox
which is to say something that can be
fully eradicated down to the very last
person who has it and then we can put a
date on the time when smallpox isn't no
longer a problem forever
whereas I and I would argue anyone who's
really thinking rationally about this
problem should view racism as more more
like a problem like murder right like
murder in New York City used to be ten
times higher than it was today just 20
years ago it was it was absolute carnage
so the the rate is it's come down
tenfold New York is notoriously safe at
this point he's something like 200
murders two or three hundred murders
last year right what would it take to
get the murder rate down to zero to the
point where there was not a single
murder in the
city you'd probably murder everybody yes
but you have to I mean you have to
embrace a totally totalitarian yeah vibe
from the top it could be done but it
would not be worth what it took to get
there you'd hit diminishing returns so I
view the problem of reducing racism
reducing racist incidents against black
people as a problem like homicide rather
than smallpox which is to say you can
certainly reduce it and we have
massively but there is a point at which
in a country of 350 million there will
always be enough people who are racist
to justify a certain amount of races
incidents and to fight it beyond that
endlessly you hit diminishing returns
yeah and also that it's depressing and
it kind of sucks but people can be
racist like privately you can be racist
you know you can't discriminate against
people and and there's all sorts of
reasons that you can't bring that into
public life but in your own mind in your
own home you can be it I would prefer
people not be but that they're trying to
eradicate like something that's actually
just part of the mind yes you want to
you want to educate people enough so
that they hopefully won't hold those
views but that is the diminishing
returns because you're literally going
to be in people's houses at that point
right yeah I mean yeah it's it's a it's
a question of not yeah I guess is a
question of what your view of human
nature is this comes down to very
fundamental pillars of one's political
ideology which is do you have a kind of
utopian view of human nature where
there's nothing tragic about us nothing
flawed about us and all of the flaws
come from bad ideas in the culture and
humans are naturally poised to be just
perfectly selfless until we get ruined
by society see that that I think there's
no reason to believe that at this point
right chimpanzees murder mmm-hmm and
like we're we're animals in the animal
kingdom it's not to say that where our
human nature is fundamentally evil
either it's it's clearly there's a
there's a wide range of potential there
but there's no no reason to assume that
we're evolved to be not racists or that
were evolved to be
woke perfectly woke or that it's
possible to get to a point where
everyone in society has been fully
purged of every ounce of evil in their
heart I mean that is such a utopian
outlook and like I said the the to the
extent that you're fixated on that goal
to the exclusion of the costs of your
fixation
once you hit diminishing returns you
will be fighting a fight that is a net
bad for society all right let's talk
about systemic racism or at least the
idea of systemic racism so I think
you've seen the video of me about two or
two and a half years ago with Larry
elder and I brought up systemic racism
larry elder proceeded to commit a hate
crime on me a white man he beat me
senseless with statistics yeah and I
came to a fight not ready to to fight
basically and that was definitely one of
my red pill moments so to speak I was
not prepared
I heard new information I did research
after that subsequently I've had many
people on this show in many
conversations that have led me to more
of Larry's original premise so I guess
first when you when you saw that moment
was that the first time you had ever
seen me do anything because that's a
little tell me and I'm like oh I don't
think it was the first time but I think
I mean I don't and envied anyone who's
debating Larry elder on anything
yes he's pretty devastating it's been
kind of refreshing though when you saw
this moment where he laid it out yeah
you know there was no counter because
there is no counter right well yeah he
he what he did with you there is he he
went through each specific venue in
which supposedly there is this big
systemic racism problem where the system
is rigged in such a way that it doesn't
require any individual in the system to
be racist in order for the system to
spit out racist outcomes that's
essentially the idea of systemic racism
so he went he went with you through he
said just name name a place in society
where you think systemic racism exists
and he just did basically destroyed each
one
the specifics of of the case and I'm not
gonna do a better job than he did there
yeah he's capable of doing but there's a
bigger picture way to test the systemic
racism hypothesis which is to take two
populations where it's it's a very messy
crude science experiment but to take two
populations where you're holding
systemic racism constant namely black
Americans like myself and black
immigrants especially black immigrants
from the West Indies and their children
we're talking about immigrants from
Jamaica Barbados other places in the
West Indies and specifically their
children they're american-born children
so these are people you could not tell
apart from black like you couldn't tell
if I didn't tell you that I wasn't the
child of a Jamaican immigrant or
something right and you find that the
thing about these is that these two
populations differ in many ways some
some some ways are very hard to quantify
but they differ culturally they differ
for all kinds of reasons because
partially because the kind of immigrant
who gets out of a Jamaica differs
systematically it's going to be
disproportionately intelligent
disproportionately hardworking whatever
the traits are that get you from Jamaica
to New York say that's a cluster of
attributes that that makes that
population differ but there's there's
one thing that is not different which is
they are subjected to whatever level of
systemic racism exists so Thomas ol has
done good work on it back in the 70s he
showed that second-generation West in
the West Indians living in the same city
as black Americans were earning 58% more
right so they're they're both being
treated to whatever degree badly by
white people they're whatever this
whatever system you want to suppose is
holding black people back is equally
affecting both of them the Columbia
sociologist van tranh has a great essay
in which the this this difference is
brought out you find neighborhoods of of
black Americans right next to Nate
hoods of black West Indians in New York
they're equally segregated from white
people so it gets rid of you know this
the idea that being segregated by a cell
or living around people who only look
like you is inherently a disadvantage it
gets around the policing issue because
these populations are being polluted the
police can't tell the difference between
the second generation West Indian end
and a black person it gets around
whatever level of systemic racism is or
isn't in the pipeline with regard to
schools and you find wildly different
outcomes you find you know rate of high
school graduation much higher for black
West Indians of rate of enrollment in
college much higher you may rate of real
professional occupations much higher
crime lower right so this suggests to me
that there are that the role of systemic
racism to whatever degree it exists is
is minimal at this point and the the the
there's a whole narrative built around
the idea that this is the primary
obstacle facing black people and it's
worth noting I don't I don't think most
black people actually believe this
because I mean they're there various
polls to cite here but there's there's
one from Pew that that asked black
people without without college education
has has race how has your race held you
back at all in life 60 percent said no
it's a recent Pew poll another Gallup
poll asked is bias the main issue facing
you in jobs and housing 60% again said
no the the Harvard sociologist Ethan
Fawcett polling of the black community
and found that disconnected black youth
which would be a black youth without who
aren't in schools and don't have a jobs
the people on the lowest rung of society
something something around 30 percent of
them think the system is rigged and
seventy percent don't so what we're
getting is we're getting the voices of
black people who believe the systemic
racism narrative promoted to the to the
most powerful media position
in our country so we're getting the
impression right this is a uniform view
and it's not right so this is sort of
the Jesse Jackson Sal sharp as they get
moved up because they're given sort of
simple answers so I guess it harkens the
question that I could ask this either
way what is it that the West Indian
immigrants are doing right or what is it
that the other folks are doing wrong
yeah yeah I mean you can answer that in
either directions on show first well
part and part of it is just immigration
selection factors that I mentioned right
so the the kind of Jamaican or Barbadian
who makes it off the island to New York
did likely to be disproportionately
hard-working disproportionately X for
whatever X Factor is and so in that
sense the direct comparison can be
misleading but just analyzing why these
two populations differ you find West
Indian immigrants more likely to come
from a two-parent home you know more
likely to have had a more classically
socially conservative upbringing which
is you know you don't talk back to your
parents parents are rather strict there
are downsides of course to that style of
parenting but it basically what I'm
saying is that there are cultural
factors that are important that differ
between these two groups right you find
if there are many I mean this is this is
where the conversation for many people
gets especially uncommon yeah right it's
the idea that every culture every
subculture is identical in the
behavioral patterns that are inculcated
and wherever there is some wherever
there is a disparity in some outcome
it's not possible that culture accounts
for some or most of that disparity which
i think is a very silly idea well
completely nonsense
yeah yeah cultures are different
different people and different groups
put different emphasis on certain things
so more on family simple more on
education simple more on sports or
whatever the hell whatever the hell it
is so when you hear larry elder make the
argument you know something around until
1972 the black family had a
higher rate of staying in marriages and
then he lays out the reasons that he
believes policies of the Democrats
destroyed all that that that obviously
resonates with you right because you're
you're giving me some piece of this both
answers I think resonate or went back to
family rates of marriage and some sort
of conservative ideals right well yeah I
mean that that's a very complex people
hate when you talk when anyone talks
about yes about family people just
absolutely hate it it is a fact that
black the the rate of two-parent homes
and marriages was pretty similar to the
white rate until the sixties it is it is
a it's a matter of scholarly dispute as
to what was the cause that it I think
it's certain at this point there was no
one cause well first date may have had
something to do with it but I think it
may have just been changing norms in the
culture what because we're seeing the
same thing happen in in in the white
working-class as well now with the
decline of of two-parent homes to a
lesser extent than has happened in the
black community
yes so so I guess what yeah so I mean we
could talk about some of the the most
important behavioral patterns that are
different between black families and
white families and Asian families I mean
there there are some statistics that I I
just I don't see any way in which this
could possibly be explained by systemic
racism for example one is that if you
ask thirteen year olds if they've had
their first sexual experience yet you
get nine percent of of whites saying yes
you get twenty one percent of black
people saying yes right so it's more
than a two-fold difference there and
that has everything to do with family
dynamics with with their not being to
parents in the home it is a development
issue more than it is an issue of
treatment by white people right I have
another piece in Collette called black
American culture and the racial wealth
gap where I talk about spending
differences and you you you know Nielsen
the the marketing firm has done done
research on this found that the average
black woman is more likely to own a
luxury vehicle than the average white
woman
despite the fact that the average black
family has one-tenth the wealth of the
average average white family spending
patterns on on jewelry and an expensive
clothes are very different in the black
community whatever you want to say about
these from an ethically this is not I
mean I'm not but I make an ethical
judgment right I mean I'm not finger
wagging at people saying do X don't do y
I'm saying there are there are entire
books written by respected left-wing
scholars about issues like wealth or
income or that just don't mention a
single one of these facts as if it's not
relevant right so what's what's the
through line then or the connection
between all of this and the welfare
state because the more that I've
explored these ideas the more that I am
starting to buy that that almost is the
the real problem here that we've given a
certain amount and then it's just human
nature people don't want to stop being
on the dole that has nothing to do with
race you could give it to anyone but in
this case we happen to be talking about
black Americans but I can give you just
one simple example which is my sister
lives in in Manhattan not that far from
you actually and she's in a building
that's part subsidized so there's a lot
of black people in the building that
have been there for generations now that
are they're subsidized my sister and her
husband two kids they're not rolling in
dough they're paying full market price
but the people that are in the
subsidized housing it's almost
impossible for them to leave I don't
even blame them because they're paying
next to nothing and if they wanted to
work more they'd probably and then get
off the subsidy the subsidies they
probably have to leave the building in
the first place I think go live
somewhere worse so we end up with this
horrific catch-22 that again I don't
believe I don't put this on race it just
seems to be affecting people of a
certain race more yes I think I mean I
think it's clear that there was a point
in in in the late 60s and 70s where the
welfare state was clearly incentivizing
counterproductive behavior
disproportionately among black people I
mean the
yeah I I don't I think we need a welfare
state I think there's there's really no
free market there's no capitalist
economy in the world that doesn't have
one because they're just and and you
know people's jobs are being taken by
automation and that's only going in one
direction and we clearly need a welfare
state and we need one that doesn't
incentivize you know counterproductive
behavior and we haven't always had that
and when you say welfare say you mean
some sort of social safety net that's
what I got yes okay because I think
people would you say welfare state I
think people have a different sort of
connotation frapps yeah I mean it's
social I mean something that catches
people who can't really can't help
themselves who can't trade their skills
for money in the market yeah yeah I'm
with you so so then how do we untether
the issue of people that are now stuck
in that machine where every time you
talk about it you're called a racist no
I mean this is it is extremely precious
because I think it's clear that the
welfare state
the way it was rolled out in the 60s and
70s had bad effects for black people
right it's it's it's hard to fully
explain the decline in two-parent homes
without noticing that a black mother in
the early 70s stood to lose money by
getting married to a guy right because
of the perverse incentives of the
welfare state that said it's not just
because the welfare state was one of the
causes of the decline of the black
family doesn't imply that taking it away
would repair it so I think I think that
is something like charles murray for
example groped the big book in the 80s
that made him big losing ground which
criticized the welfare state very much
along these grounds but i think even he
has acknowledged that at this point
removing it once you set it all into
motion it's not obvious that removing it
is a cure which is which is tragic but
true yeah it's it's a real tragedy
because then it's like I mean this is
where you would definitely have a
difference of opinion with Candace where
her argument is rip the band-aid rip the
band-aid let the pieces fall where they
may
I don't know what her policy is on then
helping like the poorest of the poor
never like are you literally gonna be
kicking people out of their houses right
I don't know what the answer to that is
yeah but I think there's there's a
growing feeling I think at least a
certain set of people that it's not
working you're acknowledging why it's
not working and these little band-aid
fixes seemingly only make it worse yeah
it's I think it's a very complex issue
because there there are some there are
some elements of the social safety net
that I think economists agree are
working like the Earned Income Tax
Credit which actually incentivizes you
to work it helps the worst off people in
society without it basically corrects
the the massive mistake of welfare in
the Lyndon Johnson era but ya know it's
it's a complex issue yeah I'm sure
so I hate to talk about race this whole
time it's like kind of annoying I know
it's what you mostly write about what
what else is kind of on your mind like
what are the other issues that you care
about I mean we can keep going on that
but I always feel like it's like it's
that's also a sort of tragedy of all of
this it's like your whole worldview is
to move past all this yes and yet
because of that you get thrust into the
conversation it's a weird weird
psychological condition I suppose yes it
is does that just drive you crazy in
general yeah I mean I don't before we
move on the race is not something I find
inherently interesting yeah I think it
is like when I have when I have a free
moment to to read a book I'm not
ordering the race book because but but
at the same time it is a topic that's
loomed so large in our politics and so
much of what is said makes so little
sense that I it it just gets to me so I
have to say something but it's not
something I enjoy I mean what I really
enjoy is philosophy and science so so
when I have free moments I tend to read
things and those in those genres yeah
well you're working for the right lady
Claire oh yeah collect yeah that's what
she cares about too so actually we can
shift a little bit so you attended an
event that there's an IDW group in New
York put together it was put together in
like two or three days it was me and
Eric Weinstein and
Faisel Matar and melissa chen and we're
just kind of doing like IDW 101 stuff
and you you asked me an interesting
question during the Q&A so i'll let you
present the question and then i want to
hear your answer actually before i
repeat my answer yeah so my question was
essentially there are a lot of people
who really don't like the intellectual
darkweb I think it's just a bunch of
cranks who are you know playing footsie
with the alt-right in this objectionable
way and totally dismiss the whole thing
but then there there are there are many
other people who think well you know I I
like I like half of the people in the in
the intellectual dark web you know I
don't maybe like the other half but I
think it's they have you know kind of
knew wants to take on it but they're
really what where one loses them is the
fact that you know you've had Stefan
Mullen no I don't know Molyneux right so
this is this character that people view
as objectionable to whatever degree I
don't know I don't follow him so I don't
know whether they should or shouldn't
view him that way
yeah but you know or sam harris has had
charles murray on the podcast which you
know many he just has a terrible
reputation on the left largely
undeserved yeah or Joe Rogan had Alex
Jones oh we can do endless infinitum
yeah and it seems like that is is the
last place where people who might
otherwise see this phenomenon as good
get off the ship yeah or I've had I
think I've had conversations with people
where that was kind of the last trench
to die in in terms of criticizing the
phenomenon so my question was what do
you like what do you think about this do
you think I mean this is also a
criticism that Barry Weiss raised in her
and her piece about it so I mean I guess
my answer to that would be I'm I mean
well do you know this guy Darrell Davis
he's a black guy who did a documentary
coat remember the name of it where he
met with the white super he met with Ku
Klux Klan members yeah as a black person
yeah and just hung out with them
talk to them about various issues became
friends with them right so imagine the
psychological courage this takes to sit
across from someone who literally thinks
you are an inferior kind of human being
and to put that aside and just expand
your circle of empathy to include them
preemptively incredibly inspirational so
and he ends up getting over 200 Ku Klux
Klan members to renounce their
membership and he keeps their robes in
his closet as a kind of trophy of having
D radicalized them okay and then he gets
harshly criticized from blacks black
lives matter for having having done this
which is which I found I find to be the
most galling irony in the world because
we're talking about a person who has
done more to reduce racism in this
society than almost anyone I could name
in black lives matter right he is he has
gone like you know many many progressive
activists they attempt to go to the
spaces that are actually the most
progressive already and try to make them
even more progressive so they show up on
the University campuses already the most
progressive places on planet Earth and
then accused them of being systemically
racist right so we're talking about a
guy who actually went into the trenches
yeah he was a belly of the beast
exactly and was successful in D
radicalizing people from white racism
the point the point I'm making here is
not not to compare obviously charles
Murray or Stephon to to a Ku Klux Klan
member my point is we ought to be
expanding the range of people we're
willing to talk to and disagree with and
I think that insofar as you're able to
challenge people or just expose expose
people's ideas I think that in the long
run as uncomfortable as it is and
counterintuitive as it is tends to tends
to be better yeah so I'll just repeat it
quickly but that in essence that last
portion especially really was my answer
now first off some of us Rogan me and
Sam particularly we interview people so
we can't say we're for you know
plurality of ideas and we want to talk
to people we disagree with and all that
and then only talk to people we agree
with
so that means we are going to talk to
some of these characters without getting
into any of the specifics of the people
that I've had on the show of course
sometimes somebody you may not ask the
right question here or there I'm not
even I'm not even saying that that's
what I did or didn't do but you have
like otherwise we're not taking any
risks and the group of people that we'll
talk to will become infinitely smaller
and smaller and smaller and also we'll
be sort of will be hostages to people
that don't like us in the first place
and that's what I'm more concerned about
it's like I don't want people who don't
want any conversation to be happening at
all to have ownership over who I'm going
to talk to yeah now on any specific
moment could any of us do something a
little bit differently sure but in
essence yeah you're asking about the
gatekeeping that that Barry was talking
about yeah I don't even know that it's
it's for me to say and as I said before
you know we don't even have it's not
like we're walking around with laminated
cards and we go to a secret meeting so
I'm right but I think the best
sunlights the best disinfectant I just I
just fundamentally believe that and as
far as I know no one was hurt by any of
the interviews that I've done and I
think I've I've helped a lot of people
that were maybe into some of those ideas
you know that was the one that people
were giving me a lot of it that's the
dance that Darrell Davis phenomenon yeah
yeah so yeah nobody's lost I mean that's
what I really believe and maybe that's a
little rose-colored glasses of me but I
believe that you know when when people
were giving me crap for doing Alex Jones
it's like forget what he thinks about
things for a moment clearly hundreds of
thousands or millions of people are
watching this I came on on a live show I
said whatever I believe I didn't lie
about anything I said the same things I
say here and then I got emails from his
people saying you know I never heard a
decent liberal talk before now I watched
your interview with Brett Weinstein it's
like wow that's pretty cool man so I
just think perhaps we and I mean you and
I in this case we just have a little bit
more tolerance for I don't think if
someone hears something it's going to
immediately infect them and then they're
gonna take that infection and infect
other people but I think a lot of people
operate in that prison I think so I mean
one of the reasons I asked this question
at the event is I was glad you did by
them yeah yeah it's because for example
Charles Murray has
retweeted some of my pieces and you know
I've gotten into exchanges with some of
my critics where I've I've kind of
talked them down off of the ledge of me
being a sellout or you know convinced
them that I'm I'm operating in good
faith and the trench they're dying and
criticizing me is well Charles Marie
retweeted you and he is XY and Z
therefore I I think a that's just that's
like two layers of ad hominem yeah ad
hominem is attacking you instead of your
belief but attacking someone else
instead of your yeah that's a bit much
yeah it's ad hominem twice over but we
seem to be in this in this place now
where people like lists you know the
SPLC is making lists of people that are
bad people you know there was this
alternative influencer graph that you
probably saw that I tried to link
together I didn't even know probably 10
or 15 of the people on there and I don't
you know and I looked at the list after
where there including me in this like
crazy whatever it was white supremacist
Lester saying not only did I not know
plenty of the people several of them I
have muted because they hate me so it's
like like you just come together with
anyone that has walked past you
oh you shook hands with that guy you
didn't know he was too bad you're you're
screwed man yeah that's it no I think I
think I was telling this to you before
we film but I think we live in a
McCarthy estera with regard to
especially racism but also other other
isms I mean I hope historians look back
on it as that but you know we're getting
we're getting people fired for you know
for saying the n-word in an anti-racist
context you know Papa John's for example
yeah the CEO of that got fired for
saying the n-word and there was no
pushback on that the guy said it in the
context of an anti-racist raises like
recalling his the racist of his youth
and the heinous things they would say
yeah right and it gets fired it gets his
name taken off the gym of his local
hometown just gets his reputation deep
sixed and right so like this is
happening it happened a month later to
to this executive at netflix who's in a
meeting about offensive
words in Netflix's comedy context so how
do you have a meeting about offensive
words without saying offensive words
unless you're just gonna be talking like
alphabets so he says this fired so these
are no nobody upon reflection thinks
that these people are racists it is
completely it is it is analogous to
McCarthyism in that sense and the word
racism has been denuded so fully of of
its of its moral valence and its moral
charge at this point that you know
people you know we're caring less and
less about actual racism - that's a fear
here right once you once you strip this
word of all this all its moral charge
then you have a boy who cried wolf
scenario which ends up backfiring
spectacularly and I would argue that
that is happening we're seeing a surge
on the on the far right as well all
right so I think that that was also my
concern I mean before the election I did
plenty of videos about you got a stop
calling Trump Hitler yeah because if he
is not Hitler and for all the reasons
that people don't like them the guy's
not Hitler and it's like you keep doing
that you won't even realize when the
real bad guys go and the people that
would be sympathetic to your views will
no longer listen to you because they'll
view you as the boy who cried wolf
yeah and Bill Maher Bill Maher called
himself out for doing this for calling
Bush and Romney racists or well whatever
it was right he said that Romney hated
women yes yes and he called himself out
for being hyperbolic so that when when
trunk trump came along who actually has
done clearly MIT has said clearly
misogynist things is alleged to have
said some things that if he did say them
are clearly racist yeah people don't
care anymore because they've been so
sullied you know they've been called
racist a thousand times by the pundits
at MSNBC and it's it's been true maybe
ten percent of the times but not true
like for the funniest case of this to me
was one when Trump called Omarosa a dog
right and watched you turn on NBC MSNBC
after this or read the New York Times
it is just obvious to those people that
this is a racist slur he's called this
black woman a dog this is obviously
racist and if you're defending it you're
a racist too okay and then you just if
you have an internet connection
yeah you look at the other people Trump
has directly called the dog you find Mac
Miller before he passed away Morris you
find David Axelrod you find Adriana
Huffington just you find white person
after white person that he is directly
called the dog not said they did
something like a dog because he likes
that construction - right but he's
called white person after white person a
dog there's no reason to believe that
this was a racist incident and yet every
pundit at MSNBC is saying that it is and
anyone who likes Trump and you know
watches Fox News they're getting these
clips exported from MSNBC seeing
themselves called as racist by a called
racist by implication or by Association
and then seeing someone like Tucker
Carlson who I have I have reservations
about but seeing someone like Tucker
Carlson make perfect sense about it just
destroy the this view with with simple
logic and facts and imagine how how
refreshing it is to have someone like
Tucker doing that and obviously like
you're gonna get tired of being called a
racist in when in cases when it's so
obviously not true and there's just a
lack of due diligence there's a lack of
any concern for for facts and for logic
and that ends up having a very bad
effect on the other end because now
Trump I mean there some things Trump has
said for which racism I think is the
best explanation I don't think he's a
Klan member I think he's a very mild
kind of New York racist of his era you
know they're their degrees of racism in
other words but the point is it's like
the the reason that Trump voters I think
for the most part excuse him on some of
the things he said is is not because or
not for the most part because of a
random upsurge in racism that happened
in 2016 but wasn't present the past
eight years you know like there are
counties that went for Obama
twice that went for Trump it is it is I
think it's largely because people are
absolutely sick of being tarred as
racists untethered to the facts of the
specific cases yeah man now we've got
just the match made in hell we've got a
group that calls everyone racist the guy
who you know is happy to fight them on
every bit of it and use that as fuel to
get his base going yeah so what do you
it's somehow well I said we were gonna
shift that race and we went right back
to the rascal yeah all right we're gonna
try to finish up a something else but
what do you even consider yourself
politically these days if I if I was
trying to label you I mean I have a
sense you know you're somewhere in that
classical liberal situation but does
that even matter to you do you do you
think of yourself a certain way I think
if you can be gender-fluid you should be
able to be fluid at this point yeah I
think I know a white woman I find your
little things used to be quite
appreciate is that I appreciate that um
no but I think I mean it is it is
strange that like politics is a social
construct political ideologies these are
fully social constructs and it seems
like we're getting more and more rigid
with the degree to which we take them
seriously obviously once you take ideas
seriously but I don't see anything to be
gained from anchoring myself to
conservatism or liberalism or
libertarianism even though I find the
wisdom in all of these three political
ideologies so yeah I mean I think I
think if I can if I can make politically
fluid a meme that would be that would be
great
I will see what I can do all right give
me one other thing besides race what are
you doing for fun tough days man I'm
reading a reading a lot about I'm taking
metaphysics taking philosophy of
language in mind both of which what are
you doing passing on and reading
metaphysics
you got a political future in front of
you oh god no problem right people often
ask me that no I would never go into
politics actually people assume that
about me which I think is really
interesting because I detest politics I
hate it so much
yeah no I don't I don't know I don't
know why I give that vibe off
but it's yeah I cannot see myself as a
politician
you're too sane that's the problem it's
been a pleasure man
likewise all right for more on Coleman
follow them on the Twitter at cold x man
[Music]